en este pueblo bañado por el río
magdalena una de cada seis personas ha
sido víctima del conflicto armado como
el exsindicalista ciro quiroz que lleva
toda una vida de lucha cuando era más
joven a peleo por los derechos de los
trabajadores y ahora lo hace por la
memoria es un 'falso positivo'
tengo bien
también víctima recibió amenazas
paramilitares cuando trabajó como líder
sindicalista en una empresa de aceite de
palma a los 90 por él pero sobre todo
por los que murieron exige verdad el
concepto la verdad
es algo sanador algo que brinda una
satisfacción a la vista y como muchos
otros en gamarra tiene esperanzas en las
conclusiones del informe final de la
comisión de la verdad
hola pero como bbva
bien bien como la mesa de víctima de
gavarra creada a partir de los acuerdos
de paz del 2016 en la comisión lleva
recogiendo testimonios de víctimas y
victimarios
unos objetivos muy claros brindar verdad
justicia y reparación y no repetición a
los colombianos en el magdalena medio la
presencia de guerrillas como lln o las
farc ep y sobre todo de grupos
paramilitares ha hecho que el trabajo
aquí sea todo un viaje
por el dolor por la vida por los hombres
abrieron sus corazones o algo para
contarnos lo bien más arriba en el cauce
fluvial en este pueblo pescador el río
es sinónimo de vida pero también ha
visto mucha sangre luz escapó por poco
de una matanza paramilitar en un
restaurante a ella la violencia le dijo
un trauma
yo sé por qué por sobre todas las cosas
pues siempre hemos tratado de de echar
adelante cerca del río en
barrancabermeja no todos han dejado
atrás la violencia
alfonso se autodenomina firmante del
acuerdo de paz pero tiene que llevar un
chaleco antibalas siempre que está en la
ciudad el que una vez fue comandante de
las farc ep es ahora objetivo militar de
las disidencias por luchar por la paz
para nosotros significa algo muy
importante
significa una garantía de la
implementación del acuerdo de paz
porque como dice la consigna
una de las consignas que vertebra la
comisión de la verdad que espera poder
dar respuestas a las víctimas